[MUSIC]
I want you to imagine a very dangerous
day.
You wake up in the morning looking like
this after a very, very peaceful night.
However, the house you've just woken up in
is in an area that's surrounded
by a place which is very prone to
earthquakes, tornadoes and hurricanes.
You get out of bed, you go down to your
bathroom.
You fill up your bathroom sink full of
water and
you push aside all of the electrical
appliances next to you.
You don't get electricuted on the way out
of the bathroom, on the way out of
the house you grab the only thing you can
find for breakfast which happens to
be a very high in fat, high in calorie,
high sugar, high cholesterol breakfast.
That's the only thing you have.
On the way out of the house you narrowly
avoid your swimming pool,
you don't fall into your swimming pool,
and you do not drown.
And as you get to your car, you narrowly
avoid eye contact with your neighbor.
>> [LAUGH]
>> Whom you know really hates you and
has an assault rifle in his back yard.
[LAUGH].
You get into your car, you start driving,
you turn on the radio,
you hear stories of ISIS, Ebola, measles,
all of these risks,
some of the most contagious and deadly
diseases to ever reach American soil.
You get to your destination, which happens
to be an airport.
You get into a giant tube of metal, you go
up 35,000 feet in the air,
supported only by wings which are narrower
narrow and thinner than your car door.
You're fine, and just before you go to
sleep,
you are reaching to the seat pocket in
front of you, you grab the bag of peanuts,
you read the choking hazard, you're fine.
You eat the peanuts, you go to sleep,
everything's okay.
Pretty dangerous day.
Did you know that out of all of these
risks that you had today, the peanuts,
the angry neighbor with the assault rifle,
the high calorie breakfast, the swimming
pool, Ebola, none of these were the most
dangerous things you did today.
It was actually getting into your car and
driving.
Every year, 1.2 million people die on our
roads.
To put that into perspective, that's the
equivalent of a jumbo jet full
of people falling out of the sky every
three hours.
Every three hours, every single day,
every single week, every single month,
every single year.
Now I came to Stanford to think what can I
do?
What is my role in preventing the massive
spectrum of human suffering?
And what can I do to substantially improve
human life?
And when I look at these statistics,
I think this is a pretty good place to
start.
Why does this happen?
What can we do about it?
Well it turns out that 93% of accidents
happen because of human error.
Why?
Because we are human.
>> [LAUGH].
>> We get careless.
We make mistakes.
We get distracted.
We're irrational.
We make bad decisions.
We are human.
The problem is though with accidents that
when we get into one,
we don't just affect ourselves but we
affect other people around us as well.
Therefore if you want to do something to
substantially reduce the number of people
who die on our roads, we need to do
something about taking out.
Some of the human elements from driving,
and replacing it by computers
that can make better, faster, more
accurate decisions on our behalf.
And it looks like this, an autonomous
vehicle.
Now as soon as I say, replacing some of
the human elements
of driving with cold hard computers, I'm
already feeling this visceral reaction
that we have in this room about extracting
from the warm, fuzzy,
emotional human elements and replacing it
with cold, hard numbers.
But I want you to go with me for one
moment.
Go with me for a second.
I want you to imagine a safer world.
I want you to imagine a safer world where
35,000 people
do not die on our roads every single year.
That's two people since this talk began.
I want you to imagine a safer world where
you do not have to share your roads
with 65% of other drivers who are using
their cell phones at the same time.
I want you to imagine a safer world where
the 112 million people who drive under the
influence of alcohol are not driving on
the same roads that my future children and
your children are going to be playing on.
And lastly I want you to imagine a, a
safer world where you never have to look
for parking again, nor pay another parking
fine, imagine that world.
Why aren't we there yet?
To me it comes down to how we make
decisions about adopting new technologies,
both as consumers and also as regulators.
You see good decision making about whether
to adopt new technology or
not, is made by understanding diligently
the benefits and the cost.
If the benefits outweigh the cost,
then you do adopt the new technology,
otherwise you do not.
The problem is that with a ton less
vehicles,
we have no idea what the benefits are,
because we haven't tried them.
We haven't given them a shot.
On the other hand, as soon as we start
thinking of the risks, given that we
live in such a risk-averse society, we
blow these risks out of proportion.
And we, we engage our irrationalities and
fears to,
to make them much larger than what they
are.
[BLANK_AUDIO]
And that's something to think about
because when we want to understand which
technologies to adopt, we need to
understand both of them.
Now, additionally to being at the GSB, I'm
also a magician and my, and my job as
a magician is to understand where the line
is drawn between perception and reality.
And when I think of the risks of
autonomous vehicles,
I don't see reality, I see perceived
risks.
I'll explain.
You see, a lot of people
think it's terrible to give up their
control of their driving to someone else,
but they have no issue about getting into
an Uber and
giving up their control of the driving to
someone they have no idea about.
They have no issue and we have no issue
about getting into an airplane and
letting our flights be controlled by
computers on autopilot.
We have no issue getting into a New York
subway or London underground and
having the, the flow of the carriages
controlled by co, co,
cold hard numerical algorithms there.
Computers already make life or death
decisions for us on a daily basis,
and it's time to apply that to the number
one cause of death
for people between the ages of 3 and 34.
So, what I ask of you is not to put aside
your
fears of autonomous vehicles but, to keep
them into proportion and
also give necessary credence to their
benefits as well.
The fact that we don't have to live in a
world where 35,000 people die
on just US roads every year.
The fact that you will not have to share
your roads with people who are either
drunk or texting, the fact that you will
have countless extra hours every year of
extra economic productivity.
What I ask of you is not to just discount
autonomous vehicles as a new
in the thing, the new fad of Silicon
Valley.
But to go out and to tell your friends, to
tell your colleagues, to tell your
family about how much safer this world
would be if we'd begin to adopt them.
One day, I want to look back into the
world that we live in today,
where there was so much unnecessary human
suffering and think that we and
autonomous vehicles were part of that
solution.
Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
[MUSIC]